le guyana petit pays oubliés du monde à
gagner à la loterie début 2020 le
pétrole va jaillir à 200 km au large de
ses côtes
beaucoup de pétrole d'ici 2025
son produit national brut aura triplé
c'est énorme mais les 750 mille
habitants du guyana un des pays les plus
pauvres du monde
vont-ils s'enrichir l'humeur du pays
balance entre espoir et scepticisme
en 2015 les bateaux de forage d'exxon
mobil ont découvert du pétrole dans la
zone de stab ruck
l'ancien nom hollandais la capitale
georgetown le premier puits a été nommé
lisa puis un autre
lisa 2 a été foré exxon en est
maintenant à 13 découvertes auxquelles
on a donné des noms de poissons en 2025
exxon mobil et ses partenaires restent
hélas chinois à c est nouveau c'est
nexen compte produire 750 mille barils
de pétrole par jour
un par habitant du guyana et c'est un
minimum
d'autres compagnies dont la canadienne
cgx explore d'autres zones très
prometteuse c'est du pétrole de très
bonne qualité
pas une goutte de pétrole ne doit
atteindre les côtes
tout sera exportée parce que
l'exploitation et l'exportation
resteront en mer
nice a été le pétrole des plateformes
sous marine sera pompée vers ce navire
ce pétrolier a été transformé en unité
flottante de stockage et de déchargement
à singapour le lisa destiny à parier
pour le guyana où il est attendu ce
mois-ci les pétroliers des clients
viendront directement faire le plein
auprès du lisa destinée d'ici 2025
il devrait y avoir cinq navires
semblables capable de pomper 750 mille
barils par jour la cote du guyana
façonné par plusieurs grands fleuves est
un écosystème animales et végétales
extrêmement fragile évidemment à terre
on se préoccupe des risques de
déversements
nous avons tout prévu répond à ceux qui
ne satisfait pas un hasard john leaders
écologistes du pays le gouvernement du
guyana à négocier des redevances de 2%
seulement avec exxon plus près de la
moitié des revenus du pétrole
lorsque les coûts d'exploration de la
compagnie seront amortis cela prendra du
temps mais on estime que dans cinq ans
le produit national brut du pays 4
milliards de dollars aura triplé
d'ici là les premières retombées
économiques viendront sous forme de
contrat et d'emplois pour les guyanien
la main d'oeuvre et de qualité totale
tech se charge de la sélection de la
formation en matière de sécurité du
personnel engagé par exxon ou ses
partenaires comme elles se couchent
louis berger originaire de singapour
brian chiens travaillent depuis presque
quarante ans pour plusieurs compagnies
pétrolières à travers le monde
un projet comme celui du guyana il n'a
jamais vu ça il ya jusqu'à 750 me mais
il ya la chance un million de barrio
facilement pour laisser le guyana a
besoin de former des ingénieurs il a des
entrepreneurs mais manque de capital
pour les financer autre désavantage la
corruption kacc bac ce moment crucial
pour le guyana le gouvernement de david
greene joe est tombé il doit organiser
des élections qu'ils retardent le plus
possible son parti est en majorité le
parti des noirs descendants d'esclaves
en face le ppp de partie des indiens
importés d'asie par les britanniques
comme travailleur en servitude à la fin
de l' esclavage
le ppp bien sûr veut récupérer un
pouvoir qu'il a monopolisé pendant
longtemps alors le pactole pour celui
qui gagne le jackpot
l'ancien président bharrat jagdeo même
s'il ne peut pas se représenter
reste l'homme fort du ppp il accuse déjà
le parti adverse de corruption et de
manque de transparence dans la gestion
du futur fonds souverain le fond de
richesses naturelles
c'est vrai les guyanien ne se font pas
trop d'illusions pour le moment même
s'il considère que le pétrole c'est une
bonne nouvelle
mon job c'est le guyana bien mauvaise
réputation en terme de corruption
les bryan chiyah s'y connaît il a
travaillé six ans dans le pays voisin
au venezuela le pire exemple au monde de
gaspillage de ressources norvège ou
venezuela
il faudra voir comment le guyana va
gérer son futur fonds de richesses
naturelles